then a widget Nobel Committee has
decided that the Nobel Peace Prize for
2007 is to be shared in two equal parts
between the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change IPCC and Albert Arnold Al
Gore jr. for their efforts to build up
and disseminate greater knowledge about
manmade climate change and to lay the
foundations for the measures that are
needed to counteract such change
indications of changes in the Earth's
future climate must be treated with the
utmost seriousness and with a
precautionary utmost in our minds
extensive climate changes may alter and
threaten the living conditions of much o
mankind they may induce large-scale
migration and lead to greater
competition for the earth's resources
such changes will place particularly
heavy burdens of the world's most
vulnerable countries there may be
increased danger of violent conflicts
and Wars within and between states
through the scientific reports it has
issued over the past two decades the
IPCC has created an ever broader
informed consensus about a connection
between human activities and global
warming thousands of scientists and
officials from over 100 countries have
collaborated to achieve greater
certainty as to the scale of the warming
whereas in the 1980s global warming
seemed to be merely an interesting
hypothesis the 1990s produced firmer
evidence in its
support in the last few years the
connections have been even clearer and
the consequence is still more apparent
Al Gore has for a long time with one of
the world's leading environmentalist
politicians he became aware at an early
stage of the climatic challenges the
world is facing his strong commitment
reflecting in political activity
lectures films and books has
strengthened the struggle against
climate change he is probably the single
individual who has done most to create
greater worldwide understanding of the
measures that need to be adopted by
awarding the Nobel Peace Prize for 2007
to the IPCC and Al Gore the Norwegian
Nobel Committee is seeking to contribute
to a sharper focus on the processes and
decisions that appear to be necessary to
protect the world's future climate and
thereby to reduce the threat to the
security of mankind action is necessary
now before climate changes moves beyond
man's control
you